[Music]
on today's show we talked to a woman who
wants to move in with her boyfriend
who's five months sober
we also talk to a young husband who's
healing after infidelity
and we talk to a young mom whose young
child is getting ready for a scary
surgery
stay tuned
hey what's up what's up this is john
with the dr john deloni's show thanks
for joining us
hope you're doing well on the dr john
dolone's show which is super weird
because it's just me so i'm talking the
third person i kind of sound like an
idiot but on this show
we talk about your relationships your
mental health your friends your family
all of it people struggling with what
they're going to do next
people trying to figure out what the
next right move is
people figuring out hey you know what
what i've been doing the last 5
10 15 months last 5 10 15 years
is not working hey most of us listening
what we've been doing
isn't working so
crazy idea let's try something new
and let's start with being a little more
grateful let's start with going from
ah to hey tell me more about that
you're the stupidest per ah
tell me why you think that's the way
that we should do that tell me why
you think that economic plan is good
tell me what to fill in the blank dude
yelling super not working fighting not
working
let's give another shot you know what's
super working though
mean comments on the internets that's
fixing everything
it's not it's not helping even one
little bit what is
is people sitting down around a table
and saying hey man
i don't really understand this tell me
some more tell me some more about it
right
so i'm so glad you're here because on
this show we talk to real people about
real things going on in their life
we try to get to the bottom of it and
help people make the next
right step so give me a call at
1-844-693-3291
that's 1-844-693-3291
go to johndaloni.comshow fill out the
form
and it will go to kelly who decides if
the sun will rise
or if it will not and then she'll decide
if you're gonna get on the show or not
look at that she's just drinking her
coffee and whatever else is mixed in
that coffee
and we don't know look at her she's
hushing me
when she hushes you your voice stops
working it's incredible right all right
so let's get right to the phones today
let's go to charlotte in san diego
california
charlotte what's going on how can i help
hey dr john thank you for taking my call
thank you for calling what's going on
thank you i've been with my partner for
about 10 months
and he's been sober for about five
months
things have been going really great and
we want to we've been talking about
moving in together
okay um so i just want to see like
what's the best way to go about that
and set boundaries to make sure that um
this is the right decision
and that we can be successful like in
our relationship together
cool all right so why why why
why this guy um that's a good question
um so i'm gonna say
probably don't move in yet that's just
good i'm just kidding go ahead so why
this dude
no no it's a good it's a good story um
he's
i feel like he gets me and understands
me in ways that
no one else has like even people that
i've known for years
um he is super hard working
he and i know that he loves me and and
he i told him that
he shows me how much he loves me before
he even told me that he loved me
um and and i'm really happy with him and
and i think that
i want to have a future with him i know
i want to have a future with him
so he almost lost me at
he gets me like nobody else gets me
and i was almost like for real yo this
was becoming the notebook so fast
but then you you brought me back around
with he works really hard and he shows
you so how does he show you that he
loves you
um he i think
the the thing that makes me um
feel that he loves me so much is that he
he remembers little things about me
things that that i enjoy or um
he just he's just always thinking of me
and always shows it with his actions so
i'm
my love language is very much like acts
of service and so he
he'll make me coffee in the morning or
he'll take my dog out for a walk um
just small things like that cool show me
that he loves me
so tell me about so the i'm guessing
that you're calling me
no i'm not even gonna guess why are you
so why are you calling if you
love him and he gets me like nobody's
ever got me before
so why not just pull the trigger
something else is holding you back what
is it
um i think it's it's the sobriety part
so
um so like i said he's only been sober
for about five months which is that's
you know that is a lot of progress i
don't want to say only um it's a lot of
progress but
um i guess i'm worried about relapsing
in the future
or um this is going to be a major life
change for him as well
so um i guess just kind of navigating
that part of things
being with a partner who is sober yeah
so
how did how did the sobriety come up you
were with him
five months before what what brought it
up
um certain behavior
um when he was drinking and stuff that
he had told me in his past about how his
drinking had affected his life
and just different issues and stuff
it was his decision to get help and to
be sober
and of course i supported it but i
wanted to make sure that it was his
decision it wasn't me telling him
that he needed to do it and um because
that's at the end of the day he's the
only one that can do that for himself
right so so what is
what is the benefit of moving in
together
um well we we spend pretty much all of
our time together when we're not working
or with
other people um and then also i just
think a natural progression
into eventually um you know getting
married starting a family
things like that okay have you ever
lived with anybody before
no so there is a un
it is so massive and
it's it's psychological but it's super
physical too
there's i don't know what it is you can
feel like you're at somebody's house 24
7
but you're not and when they move in
it's all super different
right and there's that sense like
oh you are not going home because this
is you're here
right and that's a that's a re very
real thing right and i know you're just
you can do the math on the hours
and it's super real if you talk to
newlyweds
they're that have never lived together
before you can see it in their face
like oh this is so forever
i'm gonna have to see that toothbrush
forever and it looks like he
like cleans the bottom of his car with
it before right all that stuff right
so here's here's a couple of just big
picture things okay
i am admittedly and probably
obnoxiously my wife tells me i was born
in the wrong century all the time i
don't like computers i don't like the
internets
i just prefer to live a quiet simple
life
so i'm i take this with it with a grain
of salt
i like i don't recommend people start
combining
money and don't start combining finances
until they're married
there's legal issues there is still
figuring each other out issues there's
trust issues all those things that come
into that
i'm i am real bearish i i like playing
moving in together real slow
real real slow i get in san diego man
the rent is crazy town
right i would rather see and i know you
can even do the math on it
the on you know man just we'd save a
bajillion dollars we know this is it for
us
if you know it's it go ahead and get
married then right
the math on or the data the stats on
people who move in together before
they're married is not promising
it's just not great and i don't know why
that works it seems like if people
moved in together and got to practice
being together before they got married
it would make sense that it would work
out
it just doesn't and i've even been
around
real therapists not pretend fake
therapists like me who would tell you
that
if you want to make sure you sync your
relationship go ahead and move in
together
and it's just the data and i think it
has to do with this idea that once you
get married
and you go all in you are committed i am
there's like separation is not an option
you make stuff work but when you always
know i could probably just leave this
thing
there just lingers out there and that
little crack in the door
lets in more light and more light and
more light over time and so
that's that's the first thing is the
data doesn't back up that being a wise
decision and i'm an
old fashioned old fart when it comes to
that i want to see people figure it out
and slowly slowly grind in together and
then once they're
like if you're going to get moving
together go ahead and get married go
ahead and call it right
here's the second thing i want to make
sure you
especially don't become mom
don't become sister don't become
caretaker does that make sense yes
and you said some things that are really
good like i can't make him get well
his his decision to stay sober but that
temptation will be
so so hard four months
five months after him getting out of
rehab
do you think you could i'm asking you a
question you have no idea
there's no way you can answer this but i
just want you to imagine
could you move in with him and not
become a caretaker
um i think it's
i think it's definitely possible um you
sound so
lovely you sound so responsible and
here's the
here's the other thing you sound like
somebody
who if you see injustice somewhere
you will go burn their house down for
treating somebody less than is that fair
uh i would say so yeah i would not want
to be
in and it's you you have a i'm hearing
it through the phone
and i'm halfway across the country from
you you seem to have a sense of right
and wrong that is so
missing from the world today that i'm so
glad you're in the world
right i'm so glad you exist to build the
sidewalks my kids are going to walk on
um thank you it's it i i just
it's gonna be a nightmare trying to be
somebody who is
trying to practice desire
practice romance practice learning each
other in safety
and i've been with the same person for
over 20 years
i learned crap about my wife during the
pandemic that i had no idea
we've lived in the same house for almost
20 years
and i was like who are you right
and so 10 months just by any imagination
it is what it is right you hear all the
stories about i just knew
okay cool whatever but practicing all
those things
with somebody who is five months clean
is a lot and what i'm afraid is gonna
happen
is those he begins to slip he begins to
get exhausted his old demons come
calling
and who you are as a person is someone
who's not gonna let
somebody hurt on your watch it's not
gonna let somebody fall through the
cracks
not on charlotte's watch because this is
not who charlotte is
charlotte's a trooper charlotte is
someone who loves deeply
even to the point that i'm going to love
somebody above and beyond myself
but man if you're in a new relationship
that's hard hard hard
and so what i'd rather see i'd rather
see him
begin to still he is on a journey that
is awesome he's getting well
five months in is five months in that's
still really young i don't want to
minimize it but that's
young young young into the into the well
into this new adventure
and i don't even like the word recovery
anymore by the way i
that that assumes that our our past was
something that we want to hang on to
i like that he's on five years of
learning new habits five years of
learning new ways of
navigating through the world and he has
struck
gold because he's got charlotte walking
hand in hand with him
the data tells me plus his recovery
journey tells me
plus your spirit your incredible spirit
tells me
man moving in five months out of
recovery is real quick
y'all can do what you want to i want to
see folks say i am
all in we're going to get married and
then we're going to move in together i
like it being in that order i know that
makes me old-fashioned is what it is
but i i want there to be no question no
doubt we are in this
we are in this right so charlotte
you decide what you want to do you're
grown up and you're awesome
that's my opinion on it that's my
thoughts on it um
i'm rooting for you guys i'm rooting for
him he sounds like a guy who loves you
deeply and that's cool
and he loves me in a way that no one's
ever loved me before just always say
that
at your wedding which you're gonna have
i want to make sure somebody
says that out loud that needs to be your
um whoever's your maid of honor i don't
know how that stuff
whoever's your maid of honor best pers
whatever that is i want you
to have them make sure they say that out
loud because that's awesome let me know
what you guys decide
right uh get in touch with me on the
internets you can write it through
ask john ramsey solutions.com or you can
just dm me
um but i want to know how that goes
thanks for your call let's go to jack in
huntsville alabama
jack what's up brother hey dr deloney
how's it going
good man how are you oh pretty good uh
thank you for taking
my call thanks for giving me a shout man
so what's up
yeah so so recently uh we've had an
act of infidelity within our marriage
and and i was the one at fault
circle um that one dude yeah did i
yeah let's do this let's back it up and
say
hey deloney i screwed up i need your
help say it like that
okay okay hey dr dalony i screwed up and
i need your help
you got it brother so what's up man what
happened
so um i guess this wasn't a
physical act of infidelity but it was uh
something online
an app where i i tried to reach out to
someone
from my past okay um
obviously my wife saw that and um
this was several months ago we've we've
both kind of committed to
to making things work and making things
better i've been going to see a
therapist
okay several times a month um but
there's still
how's that going good days and it's it's
good it's
i think i am learning a lot of tools
from that
and and i've been able to apply a lot of
them and it has helped
um but there's still bad days too what's
up what's a bad day mean what's that
mean
a bad day more or less you know i could
just tell that
that my wife is upset and you know i
know the cause of that
and it's it's something that it's
crushed her confidence
um you know she's wondering is this
going to happen again
things like that so i guess i'm trying
to do what i can to
to restore that trust and i know it's
not
on my timeline but it's just uh
i just want some advice on that and um
we're also expecting a child so ah
congratulations man
and why not make it more complicated
right yeah
yeah perfect timing was she um was she
pregnant when you
reached out to somebody from your past
no
okay oh so you found out about this
later
yes cool okay number one
i hate that yellow going through this
and i appreciate you
being honest from this point forward if
you've got people that you trust that
you're having this conversation with
talking in loops like you feel like
we've had this act of
infidelity just cut to it brother just
be straight
i screwed up and i am working to build
something new with
the woman that i love and that i want to
be with forever and who by the way is
not going to be the mother of my kid
cool i want you to be that direct that's
a sink that's cut to it
and get to it is that cool yep all right
so
thank you for your trust man so when you
say that she
has bad days how do you know she's
having a bad day
um i i can just read her mood uh
usually she's and i'll tell you that's
dangerous when you get into her head
right and you try to figure out what's
going on and why it's probably about
this
does she tell you hey i am having a
vulnerable day
or i just woke up thinking about that
other girl and i
just started spinning out does she tell
you those things or are you both
imagining what's going on in the other
person's head
uh probably a little both usually i ask
though
and you know if if i'd ask she's she's
pretty direct and upfront about what's
got her down okay and what weighs inside
of the house
like concrete steps have you taken to
help rebuild trust in your home have you
given her access to your phone have you
shared all your email accounts like what
are the things that you are doing
so that she can begin rebuilding trust
in a very practical way
oh yeah yeah she she has access to to
all of that and beyond
um as far as
you know actual ways i'm trying to
go about this i mean just kind of
yeah i guess with my therapist we've
talked a lot about love languages and
ways that and and then the
gottman's four horsemen i'm sure you've
heard of
just trying to be proactive and
tend to her the ways that she receives
affection and things that matter to her
kind of tend to that
so one of the things i i love you know i
like the idea of the love of languages i
like i mean gottman is
is the pinnacle right there they do more
relationship research i think anybody on
earth
one of the challenges i see especially
in young relationships
is trying to get your
like unplug your wife from who she is
and plug her into one of these
categories
and so i want you to know these are
frames but they're not her right
yeah yeah and learning to really sit
down
what what what this is kind of a loaded
question
what made you reach out to somebody else
what was missing
in your home what was missing inside of
you
i i think just well i've listened to you
for a while and i think just
um just getting another perspective on
advice you know
no no what made you reach out to
an old girlfriend oh um
yeah i think that's a loaded question i
think i've i've been trying to dive in
and that's one of the things that i've
really tried to dive in within the
therapy itself
is to find a why and i don't know if it
is one answer
you know i think it's a lot of things um
it's a lot of the wrong things i mean
there's nothing that justifies that so
i think you're really wise to
understand the complexity that i'm
usually troubled by folks who just
are able to say well it's because of
this oh man it's usually a lot messier
messier thing than that
so is your wife going to see somebody
she's not okay um i mean she's not
entirely opposed to it but
i think it was more of like this was my
mistake this is my
have you all seen anybody together no
okay i think that's primo numero uno
is you all got to see somebody together
here's why
when something like this happens
occasionally but not always
occasionally it's one idiot there's just
one idiot
in the relationship that did something
stupid and now we just gotta get that
person he or she you know gotta hit him
with a stick
and get them to change their ways
usually
there is some sort of dance there's some
sort of
i'm missing this need here so i'm trying
to fill this gap
in and then i return to my default
settings and this brings up this stuff
and it just turns into this
weird just tr
like just mess right and
moving forward yes learning the love
languages learning about the four
horsemen learning about ways you can
theoretically support her learning
about ways you can theoretically hurt
her that's important
but what's really important is y'all
learn how you all talk to each other
you all learn what safety you all learn
what desire
you all learn what the rules and
boundaries are and you decide your
relationship
which means you all have to work on
building something new together
because what's happening is right now is
you're off so
you've heard me use say this before like
you blew up the building
right how long have you all been married
a little over a year
okay i don't even say you blew it up all
right i'm not even gonna put that on you
you um you a grenade went off in one of
the in one of the
in one of the foundation pillars right
and that sucker started rocking
and what you did what y'all have done is
you went off to get some more
classes on architecture on engineering
and your job is to come back and rebuild
that pillar
that's just not how the way that's gonna
work okay
you are gonna have to both go and say
okay this building that we
had we're a year in it's a really it's a
one-story building it's little
we're gonna have to scrap it and build
something new and that's cool because
we're gonna build something stronger
more beautiful that's gonna be able to
hold a child it's gonna be able to hold
all this stuff
but we gotta do it together right and i
want you guys to do this thing together
right do y'all have any couples that are
five years 10 years
15 years ahead of y'all that you meet
with you all hang out with
oh yeah okay do they know about what
happened
no no we've kind of kept it private all
right
secrecy kills or as brene brown says
shame eat secrecy that's what feeds it
and when you shine a light on something
it loses its power
and my recommendation is you invite a
couple over that you trust that's 5
10 15 years ahead of y'all down the road
from you guys
and y'all be totally open and when your
wife opens
up and talks about how much this hurt
and how much it caught her off guard how
much she was surprised all those things
you don't get to respond
other than yeah i heard her that's it no
excuses no this isn't
yeah i really messed up and then when
you talk about it no
big just direct straightforward here's
what happened this
is this is the way this is
and that way y'all can cut to cut
through some of the nonsense but you get
that thing out of there
and your wife right now feels like she
is shouldering all of this
and she's having to reconcile i'm still
super pissed off at this dude and i'm
pregnant
but he's going to counseling like i said
he had to and he's
love languaging me right he's making my
coffee and i'm still mad and that what's
gonna happen is she's gonna
start to blame herself open this up go
see somebody together she all can
rebuild something new get some new
skills y'all are still super young into
this thing
don't give up on it especially you got a
kid on the way
go into it open-hearted open-minded
we're going to learn new skills and
i want you to start shining some light
in this thing it's going to be a part of
your story forever it is what it is what
it is
get some people who've got some wisdom
and some experience on top of you
i want to commend you for coming forward
commend you for
trying to do the work now you got to
bring her along with you this is not
something you can do on your own you got
to bring her along there with you
okay you're going to find out things
about each other you didn't know
that you like more that scare you you're
going to work on a language
of the relationship of jack and i'm
going to call her diane
jack and diane you're going to learn
that language together as you move
forward
all right appreciate you calling me in
hey um
i i got a buddy here at work forwarded
me an email
uh an article the other day and this is
just
this is just something i want to just
put out into the universe here
japan this is a february 22nd article
we'll link to it in the show notes here
japan appointed a minister of loneliness
after seeing suicide rates in the
country increase for the first time in
11 years
if you look at the suicide rates of
what's going on in the country right now
after a year of
people being stuck by themselves and
isolated um
usually we lag you know four to four to
six months three to six months behind
some of these other countries
who are ahead of us
man i
we are talking about more people in
october 2020 committed suicide than died
by covid
in japan there were 2153 suicide
deaths that month and 1765 deaths
a major group that this is impacting
which is a statistical anomaly doesn't
happen in this way
usually it's men who complete suicide
there is a 70
increase year over year of women who've
died by suicide
women are lonely and exhausted
and more and more single women live
alone in japan many of them don't have
stable employment
they are trying to figure out what's
next
they have to support their own lives
they don't have permanent jobs
and then something like this shows up
here's what i want to tell you
it's yet another another statistical
proof another
country trying to figure out how to deal
with this absolute
monster that has pervaded our cultures
across the globe for years and that is
this monster of loneliness
the pull you're up by your bootstraps
thing is a lie
it's not real it's fake it's a myth i
don't care how tough you are
i don't care how much money you make i
don't care how high up the mountain you
think you're going to climb some day
it is not real it's not real
you've got to have other people in your
life you have to and i know covet makes
that so hard
please reach out to people and please
please please
if you're gonna hurt yourself call
somebody let them know
call somebody let them know make one
call make two calls make three calls
there's text hotlines now we're gonna
link to the
us hotline here in the show notes
you matter to somebody you matter to me
if you get to the point you think your
life isn't worth anymore
make a call reach out to somebody
even if it's somebody i've talked to in
five years 10 years 15 years even it's
to a neighbor
knock on somebody's door make that call
don't do life alone don't do life alone
all right let's take one more call let's
go to jj in lancaster jj what's up
hi hi what's up how's it going
it's going all right how's it going for
you you know what it is going as it is
going right
yep i got a job in the air conditioning
or in the heat right now
and so i have very little to complain
about i'm i'm fortunate
so how can i help all right um so my
four-year-old son is going to be having
um open heart surgery in a couple months
just trying to for me myself to deal
with it in such a way that i can help
him deal with the trauma afterwards yeah
wow he's so lucky to have you as a mom
thinking ahead
so tell me about your baby boy
um so he was born with um a congenital
heart defect
um basically he's missing part of his
heart or she's severely
under formed so he's had two open heart
surgeries already
but they were as an infant okay um so
this is the first one where he'll be
like emotionally like
mature enough to like process it okay
yep you got support is what i'm asking
yeah yeah no
yeah his dad's great and yeah so what's
the prognosis
what's the outcome look like um
so that's the other thing with this is
for
lack of a better term technically his
surgeries are considered
palliative care so it's just best
quality of life for as long as possible
yeah um they don't know how long he'll
live but like
his heart defect will eventually kill
him okay
do they have any have they given you any
sort of
date on that any sort of ballpark um
well the surgery isn't old enough to
know okay
uh so there are some that
with the same defect that are in their
30s okay um
but there's they change the circulation
of his blood
so it has impact on other organs and so
there are
um comorbidities that can arise
from the other things so like you know
assuming everything goes well yes but
then there's like
chance of this happening this you know
so yeah
so just taking a pause here
man i just
i got a five-year-old and i'm telling
you i i
i can't even put myself in your shoes
and i'm sorry that you're going through
this
and you've probably cried more tears
than most of us even knew a human body
was capable is that fair
yeah um
so i i
i've got some things i can tell you um
that you can
wrap your head around and you can
process right
but i feel like the most important thing
to let you know is this is not your
fault
and i know do you know no
i know no okay genetically this is
completely an anomaly
yeah okay most of the time when i talk
to parents in a similar situation
there's that lingering
somehow we fail them and i need you to
know that's not true
okay it makes my heart full that you
know that and i want you to never
ever ever ever forget that so
how how are you and your husband
grieving
do y'all grieve similarly or do y'all
grieve differently
we grieve differently okay for sure he
is more i am a planner well and i'm a
control freak so
this is out of my control so i want to
control everything i want to plan months
in advance like come up with
contingencies for anything that might
happen and he's more like i don't want
to worry about it till it's happening
right yeah so here's the number one
thing you all need to do
both now one year from now five years
from now 10 years from now
is you have to make sure your marriage
is rock solid
and if you have you all been to a
marriage counselor since this this
diagnosis for the last couple of years
have you all managed to work through
this
we haven't been to a counselor for it i
mean we've
um we do have really good communication
i'll say like i'll tell him that you
know and he
acknowledges that we grieve differently
but like he's willing to
you know talk with me about it even
though it's not necessarily and like
when we're in the hospital like
when we're in the hospital before he was
there every single like he was there the
entire time sure
well here's um so going to a counselor
does not mean y'all are broken in fact
it's the opposite
think of it this way think of your
um the doctors who are doing this
surgery that is so
new they're gonna have to go get
specialized training to deal with this
one particular thing
y'all are dealing with something that no
couple should ever
ever ever have to deal with and that is
counting down the days on a calendar
that should never happen
right it should be the other way around
kids should be wondering when their
dumbo parents are gonna how long they're
gonna live right not the other way
around
and so instead of looking at a counselor
like y'all are busted you aren't doing
things
right think of it as y'all are gonna
have to learn some new skills for an
extraordinary situation
and it's not an indictment over what
y'all are doing in fact the fact that
y'all are still
you lit up i could hear your voice when
i just asked you about him you like this
guy don't you
he's okay you like this dude
so i want you to still like him a bunch
down the road
okay and so go to learn some new skills
go to be able to learn some new skills
so that
you can say out loud i grieve
differently here's what i need in the
in my grief here here's what i need my
grief here because here's the thing the
overarching picture here
is there's a fantasy here about what
this is going to look like and how it's
going to be and you know this it's just
going to be different now
and so instead of because you can't
build
like as my friend chris hogan says you
can't build an hd because you don't know
what that's going to look like
you need to make sure that your walking
partner and you are in perfect sync
and when you fall he knows just how to
pick you up and vice versa
he knows how you're going to be planning
to try to assume control and his
version of control by the way is to let
go of the wheel right just completely
let go it's the same thing
right it just looks differently
do you have people in your life that you
can regularly talk
to um so the funny thing is when your
kids like
bad and sad news yeah nobody really
wants to talk about it that's right
and when i bring it up it's i don't want
to talk about that it's too sad or
oh we'll just pray and it will go away
or idiots
like nobody wants to like be like wow
this really sucks except for other
parents that are going through the same
thing but they're not like my family
that's right and then you end up your
energy spent taking care of their
feelings right
yeah i always want to make put a
positive spin on you're like medical
dancing i'm sure he'll be fine like yeah
it's totally okay
we'll get through this yeah so the
reality is you got you can't do this by
yourself
you can't and the last thing on earth
you want to do
is reach out and make new friends and
new connections right now but i'm
telling you you've got to got to got to
that will be a critical part of your
care your husband's care
and your kids care is making sure you've
got people that you can call and say
this sucks and i can't breathe because
i'm crying so hard i need someone to go
pick up my kids from school
and they go gotcha or somebody you can
text
and say i can't get out of bed today i
need someone to go pick up some
trashy drive-through and they say i got
you
and somebody that says i'm gonna go
i don't know what you do for i don't
know like a manny petty i don't know
that sounded super sexist
just i'm gonna go do something super
nice for myself and
because today is that kind of freaking
day and they're gonna be like sweet i'm
dropping everything and i'm going
you have to have ride or die people in
your life right now and because you have
people around you that
they don't know what to do so they they
cut and run
unfortunately you're going to do the
hard work of connecting with those
people
i know being in grief group sucks
because you just you get in that weird
like well i don't have it as bad as them
and they've got it way worse than me and
that may be a place to start right now
but do the hard work of making sure you
got people around you
the last thing you can do is do this by
yourself
and it may be with the people that are
your oldest friends your family sit down
and have a hard conversation says i need
people who can do the following
and if they opt out then i'm not gonna
say what i was about to say if they opt
out they opt out right
but at least they know it could be
helpful for folks who don't know what to
say
they just freak out they get scared you
can have a moment of grace for them and
say here's what helps when i say this
i'd like you to say this
is that embarrassing or ridiculous yes
but it could be really helpful
um do you have a place where you can get
real information that's not the internet
yeah i am yeah i'm very involved in the
chd world
of resources and education and all that
stuff cool
so one of the things that's really
important when parents are going through
hard medical situations like you are
with their kids
is to get true information good
information and never
ever ever google anything right
yeah ever because on google on google
everyone's dying of everything all the
time they're all dying or
they're all okay everything's wonderful
right
and none of that's true right so when we
get down to your little boy
so i just glossed over you and your
husband's entire marriage and your
relationship and how you're going to
cope and manage all this stuff right
from either 4 to 35 or somewhere in
between right
the reality is you all got to get some
new skills for the journey ahead
you've got to get some new gear for
climbing mount kilimanjaro
and you got to have people in your life
that are going to hike with you okay
now when it comes to your little boy
here's a couple of things that i found
to be really successful
with kids and i'll make a recommendation
the first thing is starting with story
you can find all kinds of incredible
resources on the internets about like
go to amazon and talk about
children's books for kids who are about
to have surgery who just had surgery
what a what a narrative does what a
story does is it
externalizes it for their kid it gives
them a picture so they can see it
and it gives you guys a touch point so
you can always say remember
so and so in the story and they'll go
yeah
it gives them a way to see it because
they can't understand what pain
feels like when you're just talking
about it you and i can say man if you
put your hand on that stove it's gonna
burn we know what that is
four-year-olds don't right so a story
gives them
a picture you may even this may sound
nuts but you may even act it out
right even take a marker and draw a cool
scar
like this is where it's gonna you can
start to narrate it for him
okay another thing your husband can do
which would be super cool
is let your son draw on a with a big
thick marker right on his chest where
that scar is going to be
let him see it on daddy for a while and
it will begin to norm it and then when
he gets his own scar
your husband will be able to unbutton
his shirt if in the emergency room or in
the doctor's office and show him hey i
got one like you except mine's not near
as cool as yours
right let him practice putting bandages
on daddy
right and you're going to begin to
slowly not
norm it but you're going to give him a
picture of what this looks like
and then i would recommend talking with
the social worker that's going to be at
the hospital there
is there any sort of resources for a
play therapist
for a there are specialized counselors
who
help mediate help navigate these
conversations with parents
to talk to these kids sometimes in play
therapy
which is the language of children which
is play they can teach
kids hey this is going to really be
uncomfortable and it's going to be
hurt and sad and that's okay and look at
daddy he's got a big we drew his pretend
but you're tough because you've got to
write all those things down the road
and then navigating the fear of i hope
this works
all right i hope this goes well so i
need you to know
you're a brave mom i love your spirit i
love your heart
i love that you and your husband are
connected still
and we will be thinking and praying for
that little boy of yours i want you to
let us know how the surgery goes
and here's to more decades than we know
what to do with
decade upon decade upon decade and
um let us know about your new friends
that you get too
and those are going to be some awkward
weird conversations i can't wait to hear
all right so as we wrap up today's show
you know what we're going straight here
in 1988
after they sold like 90 or 800 billion
trillion records with their first rock
record
a lot of loudness a lot of songs that
you can't sing in public
guns and roses came out with their
appetite for destruction record and then
they surprised everybody
by circling up with an acoustic record
and on that i'll never forget
the video for the song patience right
and then a few weeks ago or maybe a few
months ago i guess now
chris cornell who recently passed away
singer of soundgarden
easily the greatest rock singer voice
ever
comes out with a record called they
don't sing like you anymore it's a
record of covers and he does a cover of
patience
that just chills me to the bone
so guns and roses did it man it's
incredible the original
and then chris cornell come came out
with his version the rare cover
that makes you go whoo whoa
and the song goes like this i shed a
tear because i'm missing you and i'm
still all right to smile
girl i think about you every day now
was a time when i wasn't sure but you
set my mind at ease and there is no
doubt you're in my heart now
said woman take it slow it'll work
itself out fine all we need is just a
little patience
said sugar make it slow and we'll come
together fine
and all we need is just a little
patience
i sit here on the steps cause i'd rather
be alone
if i can't have you right now i'll wait
dear
sometimes i get so tense but i can't
speed up the time
but you know love there's one more thing
to consider
i've been walking the streets at night
just trying to get it right
it's hard to see with so many around
i won't sing you know i don't like being
stuck
i won't do it cause i'm gonna get into
it now this has been the dr john deloney
[Music]
show